Sinclair I'll apologize because I'll
make this awkward for you right off the
bat here because I'm going to ask Tai to
talk about working with you because Thai
it is her first major role in a feature
film and she's phenomenal in it so I
have High Hopes there will be many many
more to come so what is something about
her you appreciated as a secret partner
that you are excited for more actors
you know uh I I
especially in this movie uh I had to be
in a very uh serious headspace all the
time and
um I you know a lot of the times
Dalton's sad or something like that so
it was really nice to go from like that
headspace to go back to like hanging out
in our like where like where we just
hanging out in Sinclair's there and just
have a buddy to pile around with and
just talk to about stuff and you know
when you're working on a film set
sometimes you go 12 13 14 hours into the
day and you're tired and Delirious and
Sinclair is a very fun person to be
around so we had a lot of fun thanks Ty
Sinclair I'll ask you to give Ty some
compliments too but first just so our
viewers can get to know you a little bit
more one what is your favorite scary
movie and two is there any particular
you know acting influence or movie
influence that you think is really
shaping the performer you are now and
will become in the future sure those are
great questions I think that first one
scary movie that I love and loved my
first experience of it is it
um like both sides of the disc all six
hours or however long it is
um and a performance that's influencing
me
now I'm a huge fan of Emma Thompson I
think that she's so cool like she does a
bunch of different
um like characters and I would love to
be able to do that one day
yeah some a plus name dropping right
there I've got an IT book right above my
shoulders I see very nice proof of that
reference uh now to highlight Ty's work
in the film can of course no spoilers
here but can you give me a specific
example of a scene where something he
did for you as a scene partner made all
the difference yeah I mean the way that
we worked was pretty unique in the sense
that Dalton's always coming from this
place of darkness and Chris always has
to come from this place of light
and so Tai was actually really generous
with those moments of Darkness it was
not like about him or pushing me away it
felt like I was being invited into it
which you know is maybe a cheesier way
to say that I've been invited into this
Insidious franchise by this person who's
you know at the helm of it all so it was
it was really nice working off of you in
that way thank you yeah speaking of you
being at the helm of it all Ty and also
having a a long working relationship and
friendship with uh Patrick even after
all these years of you two knowing each
other and working with each other what
is something that you saw him accomplish
on this set as a director that even made
you think like damn I never even knew
you were capable of that
um honestly just I I think the
creativeness of this Insidious film and
and just kind of some of the the the
shots that Patrick would would you know
describe to me was such enthusiasm like
he was so so excited to to to do this
movie make this movie and and he was
here for all of it and you know it was
just such a
the way that he would talk about it got
you excited about it and got you ready
to come to work every day and inspired
and ready to go and and that was
something that was really cool to to
experience love hearing about Good Vibes
on a dark set like this yes so wild
material I love this franchise I will
always keep coming back for more
congratulations thank you so much